Okay.
Now let me,
uh,
I actually would like to spend as much time as I can on,
on Durkheim's methodology.
I have a lots of notes.
Um,
uh,
this is the 24th lecture.
No,
uh,
this semester for discourse.
But let me rush through of the desk questions and just to tell you how I would
like to,
uh,
deal with them.
I think the first one is,
uh,
you know,
very obvious,
probably a bit too of years.
Uh,
and the question is how can you make it interesting?
I hope that the distinction between power and domination is clear,
right?
Bower means that somebody can impose its will on somebody else,
even if that other person opposes it.
Uh,
there is a strong element of coercion in a war,
right?
Uh,
you can coerce people to obey your command.
Domination implies that you do not have to use coercion systematically.
Um,
uh,
because people tend to internalize a,
the reasons those who have power,
um,
use in order to legitimate why they should have power.
Right?
And then this brings us to the notion of legitimacy,
right?
Legitimacy,
other claims which are made by those who have power,
which God to justify why it is reasonable that they should issue commands and
other should obey.
Uh,
so far very simple,
right?
Or what is kind of controversial about this?
Uh,
it's Scott reversal the way how labor uses the notion of legitimacy.
Normally we,
in modern democratic theory,
we believe that the system is legitimate.
Um,
then,
uh,
um,
it is,
uh,
has a popular consent.
We think about universal suffrage.
People go to free and fair elections and then they elect leaders and then they
follow those,
you know,
those elected to office this way then power is legitimate.
But I think they,
Burt wants to have a broader notion of legitimacy because a free and fair
elections operating with universal suffrage,
we'll back 100 years in human history.
And in some countries it's still does not exist and VBA does not want to
describe the last 10 minutes of human history for human history is 24 hours,
right?
He wants to offer some conceptual tools to understand the whole 24 hours.
So that's why he has these interesting of legitimacy,
which it does imply that people have to have a certain degree of belief,
uh,
in,
the validity of the legitimacy claims.
But it is a rather passive notion of belief.
They don't have to love the person in position of authority.
They do not have to elect it.
And they simply,
it's enough if they think,
well,
um,
I cannot think of a better alternative,
right?
Uh,
and other dictators could be worse than this one.
This is a dictator,
but a reasonable labor will say,
as long as this is happening,
the person in authority will not have to use squash and systematic
systematically and therefore if you'd be legitimate.
Right?
Let me also just say,
of course,
the course if element is also in domination,
right?
Um,
uh,
if people these obey the law,
then they will be coerced.
And that is certainly a promise of coercion.
Um,
Eh,
in,
uh,
even in modern free democracies,
people are put in jail.
In this country,
people are even executive,
right?
So there is an element of coercion.
Just the real question is how systematic death caution should be and for vapor.
Um,
pure exercise of authority is relatively rare and marginal.
uh,
I would say for instance,
um,
the sort of last year or two or three of,
of Hitler was gravely ill,
legitimate.
He'd not had to use massive coercion.
Um,
certain epox off rule of Stalin in the Soviet Union.
He legitimate not,
Ooh,
the rule of styling during the Second World War,
he established some legitimacy,
but when he had to in prison,
then million people,
right?
And to kill tens of thousands or hundreds of thousands,
that is an indication that this is a legitimate,
okay.
So that's the way how I would handle it,
right?
Uh,
to work around these interesting conception of legitimacy and uh,
what is for and against this.
Now this is again,
a very simple question.
Traditional and legal,
rational authority,
right?
Uh,
uh,
the basic differences,
right?
The traditional authority.
You have a personal master in legal,
rational authority.
You do not have a person master.
You'll be at the laws and the people who are in charge who was barriers.
You'll also have to obey the same laws.
What you are required to do.
And Traditional Authority is legitimated by the sanctity of age old rules.
Here again,
I think the interesting issue if I would write about his VOB val,
this is a big,
you know,
historical distinction,
um,
but VA but also uses it to describe in contemporary society different types of
organizations.
So contemporary theory has a big dose of the additional authority in it,
right?
Um,
and I would try to elaborate on this.
They are,
um,
this is,
uh,
one of the trickier questions.
Why does vapor believe that bureaucracy is efficient?
Um,
uh,
and you may agree or man made does aggravate him.
Uh,
so first of all,
I would state why vapor beliefs that bureaucracy is efficient.
I would emphasize that he thinks that bureaucracy is the most efficient in the
technical terms and not necessar role.
The other advise,
uh,
and then of course the way how he defines bureaucracy,
you know,
people are
put into position in terms of that competence.
Um,
there,
that is a rule of law.
It is a predictable environment,
a bureaucratic environment that is,
uh,
hierarchy of appeals.
If somebody makes a mistake,
you know how to appeal.
This,
of course,
all makes it,
um,
uh,
efficient.
Now vino that'd bureaucracies are often inefficient.
So how to reconcile this now there's not that way,
but it was totally insensitive to the problem of inefficiencies of
bureaucracies.
And he formulated it how that bureaucracies are caught between formal and
substantive rationality as the way how I would probably defend vapor to say he
was not that naive to believe that bureaucracies are all as efficient.
They wouldn't be efficient if they view will be purely,
it would be purely for Molly irrational,
but they are not.
Um,
and one good example is welfare bureaucracy's which to establish a kind of clear
up patron client relationships,
right between,
um,
uh,
bureaucracies and clients.
Some people refer to this as Valvia dependency,
which makes it of course,
because of inefficiency.
Now this is a
nice question to answer.
Um,
uh,
Ivy discusses a great deal.
Um,
uh,
we know that charismatic leaders at in times of crisis when are looking for a
change,
right?
So,
uh,
Barack Obama during the presidential campaign,
he has read the birth year of 40.
He knew how to frame right?
His message exactly as a cat is matic math message.
It was all about change and it was about hope,
right?
In contrast with Hillary Clinton,
um,
or John Mccain,
a boss of them emphasize that we are experienced,
uh,
this is not what people wanted to hear a than they wanted to have change.
So,
yes,
in this respect,
uh,
Barack Obama did have a charismatic appeal and this charismatic appeal did,
um,
uh,
jail,
right?
People that many people responded to his charisma.
He was criticized by his opponent that he's a Rockstar,
right?
Because people got so excited about him so he could appeal to the emotion of
people,
right?
He could appeal to them,
not of course,
as we,
again discussed in discussion sections also briefing class.
Barack Obama has a charismatic appeal,
but he operates in a legal,
rational authority.
And we just have seen that value recently.
Right.
Making a decision about the war.
Afghanistan,
right.
Well,
uh,
he had to deal with realities,
right?
Um,
uh,
so,
well the bear woods wood in the classical sense,
charisma in vapor is reserve to great religious leaders such as Muhammad or
Jesus or whatever or the grid profits.
Um,
and in this sense I get is my eyes naturally all the applicable to politicians
operating Gidley got national authority so they would have some unease to call a
Barack Obama charismatic leader.
I would think he would go and see that certain in Barack Obama had charismatic
features.
Uh,
such a,
the cliff's question,
um,
Durkheim and the study of law.
Why owners?
He starts from the study of law in analyzing a society,
um,
because he is a metal dialogical collectivists and because he wants to capture
something like the collective conscience,
which is more than the sum total of individual consciousness,
but he's also a scientist and I hope I will have little time to talk about the
methodology.
He wants to be very rigorous and he doesn't want to start Fatah ideas.
He wants to start with facts.
Well,
he is caught in a contradiction.
So collective conscience is ideas.
Wow.
How a nurse you studied them objectively.
I use,
you know,
why is a great example because law is written down,
right?
That is written law.
You can study it objectively and is not on individual consciousness but God's,
oh,
so I think this is the major reason why he is his point of departure is as an
example law because this is what he can rigorous research study can be seen as a
social fact,
right?
That this is the law and to understand why this law came into being on the road
circumstances and does it influence people?
Um,
bell of course the inspiration comes from Montesquieu.
Alright.
Uh,
well,
agreement and disagreement.
Uh,
I think the real question is whether you buy into methodological call activism
or not.
Uh,
some of you may be methodological individualist.
Um,
uh,
especially if you are an econ major,
you tend to be an economic individualists,
a,
a methodological individualists,
right?
You tend to believe that,
you know,
that are rational individual actors who pursue interest.
And you are very skeptical about anything,
which is a assume at the above.
Um,
the individuals.
So in that case,
if you are a methodological individualists,
and in fact,
I think the dominant Chinese social sciences today is methodological
individualism and a great deal of skepticism about methodological collectivism,
that can be a kind of critical,
uh,
handle on it.
Or at least you can show this is the way how it can be criticized and you can
show why you actually think that methodological collectivism is reasonable.
Okay.
The sixth question,
organic and mechanical solidarity and how this is related to Weber's die apology
for authority.
I mean,
it's,
you know,
British simple,
uh,
um,
that are very,
very important distinction.
The differences between Durkheim and Baber.
Durkheim looks at what bring society together.
The central concept is,
uh,
um,
solidarity.
A vapor looks at social conflict,
what takes society apart?
So he looks at,
uh,
um,
a struggle had an power,
right?
Um,
uh,
Viber is coming from the lineage of five would say hops.
And Nicha lie.
That's the rebellion comes from,
uh,
that is,
of course similarities.
Uh,
mechanic organic solidarity is what legal national authorities for Viber,
they tried to capture modernity.
Uh,
it borstar is similar in the sense that the outdoors or social die apologies off
societies but also types of social organization.
So in any given society and as such.
So these are some similarities.
Uh,
uh,
okay.
I think that's probably about it.
Now,
the question of Aml me,
uh,
I think we covered this recently so I don't have to refresh your memory as much.
Uh,
the notion of anime,
um,
uh,
in Durkheim comes out of the absence of sufficient regulation and this is a
temporary product,
uh,
which emerges because,
um,
uh,
yeah,
mechanical solidarity is breaking down and organic solidarity has not been
established yet.
And in the transition from mechanical solidarity,
traditional society into a modern urban industrial society,
people have a problem of regulation and value systems and that's when they are
animal meek.
But this will go away.
Uh,
what is the theory of human nature behind this?
This can be debated.
Um,
uh,
one possible argument is that since he believes that,
you know,
um,
uh,
order,
it has to come from the outside from evolver,
uh,
he tends to believe that we sell to,
order,
um,
created by associate or level collective conscience.
Um,
we've,
we're the,
uh,
the evo things.
Um,
we,
we need to be regulated,
right?
Uh,
well here of course he knows that we can be over regulated and then that's also
pathological.
But the main,
the technology at least in the transition from,
um,
uh,
mechanical to organic solidarity is the absence of triangulation.
And the trouble on that,
you know,
humans may do,
uh,
um,
more and more,
uh,
battle logic or,
or evil act.
So that is a,
um,
uh,
notion of uh,
um,
humans be needing
control over them.
Now this is a,
uh,
speaks to the age question on Ami and alienation.
The Oud in many ways,
the opposite to each other,
right?
Aliya nation means that you are over,
that you waited,
you do not,
you are not in control of your own life,
of your own faith.
Um,
that is lot of and nation means,
um,
also marks a is inspired by those.
So,
uh,
it's a kind of loose soil am conception of nature behind that.
Uh,
the problem comes from society.
It doesn't come from the individual,
right.
Um,
uh,
Vr born in society,
we are social by nature.
Um,
and uh,
if,
uh,
modernity and modern capital,
his mood would be removed.
We again,
would act socially and collectively in a good way.
So that's uh,
uh,
Andean contrast like their camps notion is that the absence of regulation,
that's what goes is pathologies.
Uh,
or right man's question.
this is uh,
something,
uh,
but uh,
I think you'll find difficulties to deal with it because you did not find a very
design chant,
Manta in any of the readings.
And indeed we did not use the word very often.
He did use it,
uh,
most critically in an ass save what he wrote after he was trying to combine his
various sociology of religions.
But,
um,
the bird and challenge meant,
uh,
is translated from the German word magic.
Um,
so these and Sean man means a situation in which diverse we thumb roses,
roses,
magic and magic is moved out of life.
And this is happening with rationalization,
right?
The big process of historical evolution is vars,
rationalization and the loss of magic and the texts,
what you have to support that is in the Protestant ethic,
they were,
makes a big deal out of it.
That's what,
especially Calvinism and the teaching of [inaudible] nation did.
It got read of magic,
right?
But though he is in a,
say a rationalist,
uh,
he sees the downside of national is the loss of magic is the price what we have
to pay for rationalization.
Uh,
and he's a bit nostalgic about the van.
It was magic and the relations magical.
Um,
uh,
so,
that is,
uh,
a kind of a permanent conditions of modernity.
Things are not getting any better.
That's I think one of them big,
big differences.
Uh,
with the,
uh,
Durkheim's notion of an on me.
Um,
uh,
the loss of magic actually,
does mean,
uh,
like,
you know,
there is a marks,
roots in marks here because the loss of magic means that actually you,
you seem to be more,
more vulnerable to fate,
right?
Magic where,
you know,
you were a magician,
you had these how to make God the omnipotent God to do things for you,
for instance.
Um,
uh,
to save you right now,
you could do it to magic.
We means in a rational as well.
We are,
uh,
less in control of our lives.
So in this sense,
I think labor notion of design chairman that is closer to the Marxian notion of
alienation rather than the Durkheimian notion of an army.
Now social causes of suicide.
Uh,
well we just covered this,
the uh,
uh,
last lecture,
the argument is right that we believe that suicide is the most individual
intimate decision.
He actually does show and demonstrate.
This is not the case because there are great differences.
Um,
uh,
in suicide rate across countries,
there's differences tend to be very stable that are also strong relationship
between suicide and religion and suicide and education.
And therefore there are right social determinants of this very individualistic
action.
Um,
as,
as a suicide.
Now there are these two dimensions in which you can conceptualize suicide,
how well integrated you are,
um,
or how they're regulated.
You are,
and they will kind of has this idea that too much integration and too much
regulation or Doolittle integration or too little regulation.
Our boss at more and more is for the golden middle road.
Um,
uh,
um,
normality is in the middle of the road,
uh,
sort of and economics.
Uh,
so he side happens and then you are not sufficiently regulated.
Um,
egoistic,
suicidal curse.
When you are not sufficiently integrated in society,
that's when you are act egoistical.
He commits suicide because you don't care how you're yourself killing yourself.
You'll effect,
you'll be loved violence because you don't have,
be the of once you are not integrated in society,
right?
Uh,
you do not commit egoistic suicide when you care about the beloved violence and
you don't want to cause them pain by killing yourself.
Right?
Um,
and I'm like suicide have man's,
if people are kind of,
uh,
um,
not sufficiently regulated and therefore,
uh,
they,
in this Annemieke situation may make commit suicide.
Okay.
So that's about it.
And let me then move on to,
uh,
Durkheim's methodology.
Yeah.
Non Fancy for,
yeah.
So this is the rules of sociological method published in 1995,
uh,
two years after the division of labor and two years before the suicide about a
foreshadow was and combines elements from balls.
I have a lot of stuff still.
Ivo Rush you through.
One question is what he deals at.
Uh,
van is a fact sore shard and can be talking about social facts down.
He asks,
how can the observe sore shoulder vac facts?
Then he makes a distinction between normal and pathological states.
Um,
uh,
he also writes about nominalism and realism and offers an alternative to
nominalism and realism.
What is she?
System of classifications.
And then he addresses the issue of the question of explanation and causality.
Very Bass breaking guy.
The years in his Stein's,
um,
sort of any is a fact social.
Uh,
and the first point is valve.
You have to make a distinction between social and biological or psychological
fair.
My mammo,
uh,
well,
and he,
then he also,
I will elaborate on this and then he asked the question,
how objective be social facts?
The biological facts are obviously objective,
psychological,
not so obviously the source or the least.
So why are they still objective?
And then he labors on what makes her social facts elective as such.
And that is of course,
education is a major mechanism.
Okay.
So let's,
uh,
as the question,
you know,
what is the social effect as distinct from biological or psychological?
Uh,
he sat val,
if all facts,
a fact human beings,
uh,
would be,
regarded as social.
They'll would be no real discipline.
What he should be called sociology.
That,
as I pointed out before,
and I,
he's the first person who identifies emphatically with the discipline of
sociology.
Uh,
he actually has this notion of life sciences,
interestingly,
right?
And sociology is part of life sciences.
So I that are three live sciences,
sociology,
biology,
I'm psychology.
But these three different life sciences deal with different units of analysis.
There'll be different objects.
And I had a biology dios feed the body.
Uh,
uh,
psychology needs to be the personality,
while sociology needs,
this is his dick,
right?
Uh,
in the US with the collective representations a right,
he tries to move beyond the idea of collective consciousness,
collective representation,
which somehow objectively,
um,
embodies as a fact the,
uh,
the states of collective consciousness.
Um,
and therefore he said this is indeed the set of phenomena.
Ivy,
we'll be able to distinguish with other,
uh,
facts.
So when,
when do I act socially?
You know,
as a question I do.
So,
uh,
when I execute my contract,
right,
I perform duties right now,
which are defined externally to me,
right?
If I perform my duties and I have thing socially,
I'm the socially irresponsible person seems to be very street for London.
Obvious.
Okay.
How about how objective they are steady at first?
Look,
it doesn't look to object to because the sense of obligation seems to be very
subjective,
right?
Uh,
you may occasionally say to your partner,
you are irresponsible,
right?
By which you mean,
you know,
you don't have enough of a feeling of a Juki door,
watch me.
Right?
Um,
so that is,
uh,
these subjective element involved in this.
But he said,
nevertheless,
we can see this is still objective.
Um,
and one of the major way how we can understand that is objective and uh,
uh,
in fact,
um,
uh,
that is some external enforcement,
right?
These obligations,
if you keep breaking these obligations,
that will be panel this against you,
right?
Well,
not all the time.
Occasionally you can get away with it,
but at one point there may be punishment.
You see others being punished by not fulfilling that UTS or obligations and
therefore,
uh,
or you can see that that is externally and forced.
It's not just subjective thing that you have.
You think you have duties,
right?
It will be externally,
um,
uh,
you know,
implement it so you have obligations,
right?
That's 7:00 PM today to go on the Internet.
Oh,
Lord.
Questions,
right.
Um,
uh,
do answer two of them.
Uh,
well,
uh,
this of course,
you know,
calm as a subjective feelings of a in you.
It's a have enough guilt feelings if you don't do it in a timely manner,
if you would be late,
uh,
it's sufficiently internalized in you,
about,
uh,
you know,
you know that that word locations and people were late written assignments and
there were,
you know,
teaching fellows or professors who the dark right.
Something from their grades.
So therefore you don't want to risk a lower the grade and beyond,
you know,
your deep personal commitment that I want to fulfill my duty in a timely manner
right now is also a concern that if I don't,
I may get some penalty.
Right?
So that's what it makes it social.
All right.
Okay.
Uh,
so,
um,
well it has to be called active.
It cannot be just the individual.
Uh,
we have,
uh,
you know,
we have a collective sense of,
uh,
or obligations.
So,
um,
and he was used the term habits.
It's a very good term.
Uh,
uh,
which,
um,
I don't think has been used before him.
So forcefully as jury time.
Dad became very widely used the,
um,
more recently following an other great French sociologist,
Pierre Bourdieu,
who churn this turn hobby into a term hubby tools,
right?
Well,
habit habitus,
Moore's manners,
uh,
ways of life,
right?
Means that we have,
uh,
something,
um,
uh,
we,
we know how to navigate in social life,
right?
We know how to deal with situations.
These are habits,
the ways how the behave in social life.
And he said,
where does it come from?
You said,
this is coming from education,
right?
It's uh,
uh,
you are being educated.
You know,
what you are suppose to do.
Um,
well,
uh,
that's not exactly right what hops,
man hops had this idea right,
of manners and customs,
but he believed that these manners and customs simply he could explain from the
individual individual actors,
right?
The individuals act and then they know that that will be an order and alter who
will respond,
uh,
the evaluate what the possible onset of the Altera VOB and therefore they will
learn ways how to navigate anticipating possible punishment from Arthur's.
Right?
So he hops can do it,
uh,
by,
doing a methodological individualists exercise there.
Okay.
Ma'Am?
Exercises.
No,
I mean this is not how we learn it,
uh,
through acting and getting punishment and seeing that as being punished.
It is through the system of education.
Now there's a good,
good point,
an interesting point.
Um,
now,
uh,
and here again,
right?
This is kind of crystallized in these of acting.
That's what habit or a,
in the more contemporary version hobby toast,
uh,
is,
is all about,
right.
I think I'm bored.
You also means that Habitudes is something what you learned and carry in
yourself.
Uh,
and,
uh,
depending what your habits are,
habits are a veal mean that how you will fit in defense situation.
Um,
uh,
we,
we occasionally think that people get into positions where they don't have the
appropriate habitus to behave right.
And therefore they may not be performing a task very bad because they do not
have the proper habits.
The habits are kind of internalized earlier in life.
And then it helps us to perform different functions in society.
Well,
I have good rush.
So how do we observe social facts?
And now here comes so the social effects are things,
uh,
and what we need as a rigorous discipline,
right?
For a social analysis.
And that also implies that we have to get read of all of our preconceptions.
We have to define the objectives of our investigations independently from our
values.
Uh,
it's almost a value free science.
What is our use IBC and not quiet.
And we have to get rid of those data.
The cool subjective sort of.
So short facts are things,
objects.
Well,
this is a very interesting citation.
What you would not expect from the car to come and reads all slide Karl Marx in
the algae,
like the proper science should not be proceed from ideas to things,
but from dings to two ideas,
right?
It's three.
It's almost identical to the German ideology,
but the,
of course means something different.
Right?
The things are not property relations,
right?
The things I'd actually collective manifestations,
We're elected by the years.
Uh,
so,
uh,
the notion of thing is used here.
You're very in a very unique and very different way.
But what he emphasizes,
right?
That they are not the individual ideas,
but they are kind of crystallized.
Uh,
and it's out there over us.
like things,
uh,
what we cannot change.
Individuals cannot really change.
Um,
and he said,
well,
social sciences have ev war just like natural sciences,
uh,
by getting red of prejudices,
right?
Um,
uh,
dogmas moving beyond dogmas and substitute them with the study of facts.
That's what Bacon,
the philosopher,
I think 17th century suggested all scientific investigation should strive,
uh,
from induction,
from the observance of,
um,
sensually observable facts.
So he in walks baker,
right?
That this is the scientific method,
Uh,
um,
well,
it,
it is not necesarrily sensors and as a,
which is emphasized in,
uh,
in,
in Durkheim,
but moving beyond preconceptions and dogmas.
And he said,
well,
the theory should be on only introduced when science is sufficiently at advanced
stage.
Now this is a very good advice to people who are graduate students and doing
this.
Septations don't start with theory,
right?
Start by analyzing social facts and menu sufficiently advanced.
That's when you find the proper theory.
Now you will be doing your senior thesis.
I think it's a good advice to take,
right?
Don't start with the big words.
Start with,
uh,
with actual analysis and find,
um,
to Uri van.
Uh,
um,
uh,
you already have a scientific idea and here he comes.
I'm a strong critique of economist of his time.
A critique what some people will say would apply to economies today and he said,
cannot Mr today principally are occupied how the economy or Hoover Erick rather
than to understanding how the economy actually works.
Right?
Uh,
Paul Krugman,
just publish the little piece in New York Times a couple of weeks ago now.
Yeah.
Actually accused his own colleagues.
He said you created these mass,
you know,
with the financial markets because you were never looking at how the economy
really works.
You operated how the economy should be variety,
but we really should be studying how the economy works.
So it's an interesting criticism of economics.
What I mean,
not necessarily true for all economies,
then it's,
it can be debated whether a normative science,
which describes how something should operate is illegitimate,
but he certainly takes the idea that it should not be a normative,
well,
we have to get read of preconceptions.
Right?
And he said they caught and bacon disagreed with each other.
Right.
As I said,
bacon was the one who said the analysis should start from,
um,
induction observing
phenomena of what we can censor sleep study and then moved over his theorizing
greeter they cards that was opting for that deducting mattered.
He said,
well,
we have to start from general abstractions and then to move the,
the derived hypothesis from these general and then to move to the facts.
These are,
this is the difference between Bake Bacon and Descartes,
but he said,
but they do agri involved thing,
namely that no matter that their reasoning is inductive,
right,
from observation to theory or deducted from theory to observation,
they agree that we should get rid of the dogmas.
Um,
uh,
no preconceptions.
And he said,
this is particularly difficult in social sciences because we think we know how
society works.
We don't,
there's just a real thing.
We need social scientists to tell us how society works,
the experience society,
and therefore we have an idea how it works.
And we have strong interest.
Harvey would want society to work.
And if,
uh,
the conception,
if the findings goes against our interests or beliefs,
strong sentiments,
we tend to disregard it.
So it's very difficult to get read of Dogmas in social sciences because we have
an ordinary knowledge,
right?
Not Scientific,
but ordinary knowledge.
How society and the economy operates.
Right.
And he had an interest as well as very enrolled,
so very difficult to get rid of our preconceptions.
Now he said,
well,
yes,
because we have very strong sentiments and that's okay.
Uh,
be sure to study the sentiments that centi national study as,
as if they were objects.
The what?
They should not be led by sentiments.
Right?
Uh,
uh,
we have to proceed,
visit,
uh,
passion and be south,
prejudices
bell.
We have to define the objects of our investigation independently from our,
our values as such.
Um,
uh,
um,
and therefore he said,
we have to come up with objective definitions of what we are studying.
He said,
what is a crime?
crime is a social act which,
which are punished.
Therefore,
I don't have to make a value judgment in defining crime.
If I see a society in which certain act,
uh,
systematically punished by that society.
I can say in this society,
this is defined as a crime.
I may disagree with this.
I may see this should not be a crime,
but in this society it is a crime.
In many societies,
for instance,
a homosexual acts were defined as a crime.
In those societies,
they were a crime.
You can disagree with it and you should say,
well,
homosexuality should be decriminalized.
That as it was fortunately,
I mean their lives,
it's not a crime any longer.
Uh,
Rahel smoking and selling Mariajuana is a crime,
right?
It is being punished.
You can end up in jail,
had some effect.
You may think that marijuana should be decriminalized,
or the fact that the consumption of marijuana and marketing of marijuana is a
crime today in the United States is an objective fact.
Right?
And it can be studied by looking at the law and what on earth judges do in this
country.
Right?
So that's uh,
um,
his,
his point,
it's,
it doesn't matter what your values are and what matters for the practices of
society are the St Louis for morality,
he said,
well,
some people will be saved.
How they are immoral because they are differently than I do.
He said,
no,
every society has morality.
You have to understand what their morality is,
even if it is a different from your own morality.
Now we have to disregard to subjective,
uh,
information.
So,
uh,
this is what scientists do when they use measures and instruments that what,
you know,
he's very much attracted to.
Uh,
the scientific reasoning in sociology is a very French idea.
And then he makes a distinction between normal and pathologic goals.
So what is the difference between normal and pathological?
Now,
he said normally is the most frequent for a faction,
right?
Uh,
uh,
we need our conception for normality because we just cannot operate.
You saw defining,
uh,
Dora,
but how can we do that?
And at the same time remain objective and we can say something is abnormal.
We start us Minka he said,
it's easy because what we shall do that we should regard those as normal,
which is sort of the most common way of act and to define the extremes as
abnormal.
And he said,
the reason for this is that it would be incomprehensible,
uh,
in the most widespread actor will not at the same time the most advantageous,
wrong,
but then he takes it back.
He said,
well,
we can actually see a number of occasions when frequently,
uh,
behavior of which is frequently followed is actually not useful.
Uh,
in this case,
in it may be inherited,
inherited from the past.
It may have been functional at one point of time,
the situation changed and people still keep that habit and they still keep
behaving that way.
And that can be now defined as a normal door.
It can be probably quite average behavior,
right?
Uh,
think of racism for instance,
is a good example.
All right.
Um,
uh,
well that is a very interesting argument about crime.
He said,
well,
if crime looks like it is indeed by definition pathological,
but is it Neil said,
well,
crime is present in all societies.
Uh,
so,
uh,
when his,
he makes this very interesting argument and therefore the early,
I think we are crime abnormal,
if that are too much crime in society.
Ryan per se,
is a normal state as such.
Well,
I think I leave these nominalism realism or human out,
uh,
you know,
put it on the Internet
about causality.
I finish with the idea of causality.
He said,
well,
the task of social sciences is to explain and not only to describe,
to be able to deal with the causes and causality,
and there are different methods how to do causality.
He says,
in social sciences,
the typical method is competitive,
uh,
rather than expiry mantle.
In natural sciences,
we do experiments in social sciences.
We can't expand.
The man does assume that we assign a certain stimuli randomly to a population
and then to see how they respond to this stimulus.
We can't do that in society.
And I'm,
as I mentioned about the,
uh,
suicide,
we cannot,
uh,
assigned people to get married and others to assign,
not to get married and to study later on what the effect of marriage was on
something like suicide.
So therefore,
what we can do is the comparative method.
Now,
uh,
I think I am out of time.
He makes a distinction between two types of comparative matters.
Uh,
the competitive methods,
uh,
can be,
um,
uh,
either the method of agreement,
a method of agreement if I compare to similar type of societies,
for instance,
the United States and Canada,
and to see whether that is difference between these two countries.
Uh,
for instance,
uh,
the lever,
I have a theory that a poverty may be related to crime.
People in,
you know,
who are hungry are more,
more likely to steal food,
right?
Because they have to feed themselves to put it very simply.
And I can't bear to societies by the level of property above earth.
He is the same.
And then I will see that,
uh,
you know,
it is indeed a,
uh,
where people are more likely to commit certain type of car,
the crimes or I can do the method of difference and the merit of difference.
If I compare two very different countries,
I can't build the United States with Bangladesh.
That is a very different rate of crime,
right?
And then I see whether there is a difference,
um,
in,
in climate as such.
He said the problem with this method is,
um,
uh,
there,
there is not enough cases and therefore the proper mattered.
Interestingly hard use is correlation,
but we have to do is to find what the correlation between two variables.
Now this was guiding contemporary social sciences,
but there came a smarter than most number crunchers in social sciences because
here,
I think the last sentence,
what I show you is important.
Now you have to make sure that,
uh,
the relationship,
what the causal relationship shows is really close.
All right?
And therefore we shall investigate by the aid of deduction how one of the two
terms has produced the other one.
Right now today we would say,
uh,
what Durkheim is suggesting,
if you want to establish real causality,
short of the possibility of an expanding mount or metro,
you'll have to figure out what is the cause or mechanism.
But relates the two phenomena to gather,
which as statistically correlated to each other,
statistical correlation does not necessarily show that they are,
one is causing the other one,
right?
Uh,
there are,
uh,
that,
you know,
you have a theory that the storage brings the baby and then you test this and
you show that,
you know,
fertility in Scandinavia is low and there are not many stuartship.
So you have a very strong correlation between number of starches and number of
babies being born.
This still does not sure that,
right.
The storage is bring the babies,
right?
Therefore,
you have to look at the causal mechanism,
how babies are being produced.
That's basically,
I think a very early insightful are human by your cams methodology.
And that's about it.
Thank you.
[inaudible].